[Musique]
de retour au direct depuis l'université
des maires de marly-le-roi nous allons
aborder un problème qui touche beaucoup
de gens beaucoup de communes sur ce
territoire c'est le haut débit et pour
en parler
barton sidrac bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice des yvelines et vous êtes
rapporteur d'une proposition de loi sur
le numérique et notamment qui concerne
le haut débit
et puis laurent rochette vous êtes le
directeur des opérations d'yveline
numérique c'est vous qui êtes en charge
va de mettre leurs débuts partout et je
crois que ça devrait terminer si les six
secondes il est vrai en 2020
c'est ça c'est absolument ça selon
plusieurs modalités en fonction des
différentes zones du territoire
alors on va parler parce qu'évidemment
il ya des zones plusieurs belles où
c'est plus facile des zones rurales où
c'est plus compliqué et c'est celle dont
vous occuper le plus précisément est
exact c'est exact le bon nom mais je
vous en prie je vous employez
disons que la collectivité est à la fois
en charge de veiller à ce que les choses
se déroulent bien dans la partie danse
où effectivement ce sont plutôt les
opérateurs qui sont en charge de
déploiement dans les parties danse et en
charge plus directement sur les zones
moins denses mais la collectivité à bien
cette mission de cohérence d'ensemble
même si elle est plus active sur les
zones moins denses alors parler parce
que c'est évidemment important pour les
bains dans les petits villages dans les
campagnes d'avoir d'avoir le haut débit
s'est dit maintenant il ya une nécessité
pour beaucoup alors maintenant quels
sont les enjeux du numérique est
justement du haut débit déjà tôle sur le
territoire mais au niveau national alors
le haut débit
je pense qu'on est tous aujourd'hui
conscient qu'on ne peut pas s'en passer
pour une raison toute simple c'est que
nos nos besoins en fait des usages
numériques sont de plus en plus
gourmands et si on ne fait pas cette
7 ce déploiement du haut débit dans
l'ensemble de nos territoires
un moment donné on aura de vraies
difficultés quand je dis un moment donné
nous avons des territoires aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont un certain nombre de
difficultés du merci les yvelines sont
plus préservées de ce point de vue que
nous avons sept
cette vision qui est qui nous est propre
dans les yvelines autour du numérique et
qui a été lancée initiée depuis quelques
temps voilà donc le déploiement dans les
yvelines
aujourd'hui les échéances sont claires
sont annoncés se fait dans des
conditions tout à fait attendu est
correct c'est ce qui avait été annoncé
c'est ce qui se fait toutefois à
l'échelon national mais en tant que
parlementaire le texte de loi que j'ai
défendue qui est la proposition de
patrick chaize mon collègue sénateur de
l'ain c'était justement pour permettre
le déploiement du très haut débit sur
l'ensemble du territoire que ce soit
dans des zones denses ou des zones moins
denses et puis il y avait le sujet vous
savez du dernier mètre c'est à dire que
lorsque l'on a en fait un déploiement du
numérique ou du très haut débit parfois
nous avons la difficulté de savoir vise
à financer
finalement je l'on dit le dernier mètre
entre le l'arrivée donc de ce très haut
débit l'usagé finalise avec tes pas
forcément juste n'est pas à côté du
boîtier
mais c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup parlé
de facture sociale il ya aussi un risque
de fracture numérique sur le territoire
dire que les jo ne soit pas égaux face à
quelque chose dont vous disiez vous avez
raison de dire maintenant c'est devenu
un besoin un besoin absolu on n'attend
pas trois heures avant de charger une
photo on a besoin de voir des images etc
donc on a besoin de ça et donc cette
fracture numérique lll peu qu'elle peut
constituer des des inégalités sur le
territoire alors bien évidemment elle
crée d'ailleurs parfois des inégalités
entre lesdites territoire mais aussi
entre les usagers on n'est pas tous
égaux face à usages du numérique
donc je crois qu'il faut que nous soyons
tous collectivement conscient que vous
avez d'un côté les infrastructures
c'était le sens en fait du texte de loi
que j'ai rapporté que j'ai défendue au
sénat mais vous avez aussi une fracture
numérique des usages c'est à dire que
vous avez des personnes qui sont
parfaitement à l'aise et vous avez des
personnes qui le sont moins
je pense que
les deux vont de pair il ne faut pas
opposer les usages aux infrastructures
en revanche il ne peut pas y avoir un
développement est considérée des usages
si nous n'avons pas de bonnes
infrastructures
or ce n'est pas forcément le sujet
auquel on sait quand vous parlez des des
différences d'usagé c'est quoi c'est
plutôt les personnes âgées et les plus
jeunes c'est plus différents que sap le
plus compliqué c'est un petit peu plus
nuancé je dirais ça c'est un petit peu
plus nuancé certes il ya l'aspect âge en
fait on n'est pas des digital natives
pour la plupart d'entre nous à moi même
je ne suis pas né avec
il fallait s'y faire voilà la
reconversion s'est faite à un âge on va
dire jeunes donc ça allait pour nous
mais nous avons aussi beaucoup de
personnes plus seniors qui sont beaucoup
moins à l'aise et nous avons aussi des
jeunes qui sont parfois éloignés des
usages numériques qui ont toutes tous
parfois un iphone ou un voile à un
smartphone dans leur poche mais qui ne
l'utilisent pas forcément avec tout ce
que cet objet aujourd'hui peut leur
permettre comme comme usages numériques
donc le sens un petit peu de tout ceux
qui aimeront dans ce dans ces domaines
là qui s'intéressent à ces domaines là
c'est de permettre au plus grand nombre
d'avoir le plaque c'est le plus facile
au très haut débit
j'entends dire que c'est vraiment ça le
l'avenir et avec une possibilité d'accès
presque je dirais de facilitation que ça
devienne naturel d'avoir le numérique et
de s'en servir comme un outil du
quotidien sans que ce soit réservé à une
j'ai pas dire une élite ma des gens qui
seraient peut-être à des spéculations
tout à fait et ça veut dire quoi d'une
formation ça veut dire alors formation
usage moi je crois que tout va la
formation quand on veut en faire aussi
des métiers vous savez aussi qui est un
enjeu à la fois un du ciel mais aussi un
enjeu de métiers autour du numérique
aujourd'hui de la formation d'ailleurs
dans notre territoire
j'ai assisté cette semaine à l'ouverture
d'une web d'une école du web à poissy
qui a en fait dans un quartier politique
de la ville à saint germain en laye vous
l'avez ça ne vous a peut-être pas
échappé on
annoncée puisque j'étais à subjective
oui absolument et puis j'étais à
l'initiative donc on ouvre en novembre
une école de l'intelligence artificielle
dans le cadre des écoles de
l'intelligence artificielle microsoft
simplon tout ça pour dire quoi tout ça
pour dire qu'on a tous collectivement
identifié ce besoin en talents du
numérique pour permettre justement ce
que nos concitoyens puisque l'objectif
il est quand même là puissent tous assez
facilement accéder à ces services que le
numérique offre mais pour qu'il puisse
accéder à ces services que le numérique
offre il faut aussi que nous ayons et là
je me tourne vers monsieur rochelle que
nous ayons les infrastructures des
sommes qui vont avec
non voilà la boucle est bouclée 6 e donc
s'occupe yvin numérique
un homme aussi quoi yvelines numérique
au livre numérique c'est le regroupement
du département et de ce qu'on a
l'habitude d'appeler le bloc communal
est à dire les intercommunalités et les
communes qui se regroupent donc pour
constituer un outil à qui on demande
d'abord une représentativité forte
et puis le développement d'une certaine
expertise face à des acteurs
professionnels qui eux sont de vrais
experts et donc c'est évident numérique
qui est chargé de
d'installer si je peux dire le haut
débit afin de gouverner si voilà j'ai
effectivement envoyé le bon terme c'est
yves les numériques est chargé de mettre
en place la gouvernance des projets
visant à ce que tout le monde bénéficie
effectivement du très haut débit d'ici à
d'ici à 2020 sur le sur la partie sur la
partie la moins dense nous étions
confrontés un vrai défi qui est que
alors cette partie la moins dense dans
les yvelines c'est à peu près 160 162
points 60 ans voilà c'est ça à peu près
cent mille foyers
voilà et finalement le dispositif tel
qu'il est prévu de manière standard dans
les textes et on va dire dans les
habitudes aujourd'hui de manière
générale c'est que sur ces zones là
ayant sur le papier des difficultés à
trouver une rentabilité pour ses projets
économiques les opérateurs s'appuient
sur des projets qui sont initié et
financé par les collectivités locales ou
à minima co financé par les
collectivités donc dans notre cas de
figure
ça signifiait un projet d'une centaine
de millions d'euros pour faire pour
faire simple c'est à peu près 1000 euros
et demi le parisien jeudi 0 après mille
euros une prise il ya cent mille et un
peu plus de 100000 prisa à desservir les
festivités c'est un énorme chantier et
on est quand même dans une période ça
n'est pas je dirais que c'est un lieu
commun de dire ça maintenant les
collectivités sont confrontés à de
nombreux défis financiers et donc on a
souhaité regarder
est ce que finalement on doit vraiment
investis à ce qu'on peut vraiment faire
ce projet sans investir 7 centaines de
millions est ce qu'on peut arriver à
mimer un acteur en inventant créant un
modèle un peu particulier un peu
différent de celui qui se déroulait en
standard auquel les opérateurs ont
l'habitude d'être co financé ou bien est
ce que finalement on va être obligés
d'investir 600 millions voilà donc on
est la vaisselle lave sur la demande est
là vous êtes dans la réflexion de là on
est dans la réalisation puisque
conditions et on a répondu à cette
question dans le sens où finalement le
travail de discussions que nous avons
eues avec les opérateurs en faisant
valoir aussi un les spécificités et les
atouts du territoire yvelinois et qui
pouvait nous semble et il présentait un
intérêt et une forme de rentabilité pour
les opérateurs
nous avons fini à l'issue d'une
consultation par identifier trois
opérateurs candidats est un lauréat qui
ont accepté de fibres et ses cent mille
prise d'ici à fin 2020 et donc d'assumer
ce chantier à 100 millions d'euros sans
un seul euro d'investissement public
public les uns sans argent public 1 sans
argent public voilà donc ça c'est un
modèle innovant et le gagnant c'est qui
le gagnant s'appelle tdf inquiétude à
une société
voilà qui c'est qui a dû trouver des ce
qu'on a l'habitude d'appeler des relais
de croissance sur laquelle les métiers
traditionnels ne connaissait plus de
croissance et qui a trouvé un relais de
croissance en adressant le marché de dés
des réseaux fibre optique qui lui est en
pleine croissance évidemment et donc tdf
s'est positionné et a fait l'offre la
plus convaincante
c'est donc celle que les et de nos élus
ont retenu ont choisi il ya quand même
des mauvais perdants si je veux dire ou
pas va y aller
est-ce que les autres opérateurs
essaient d'entrer dans ce qu'est ce qui
est intéressant c'est que nous avions
trois candidats et je vais vous dire
quand nous avons lancé cette
consultation en dix ans y at il un
opérateur qui seraient prêts à fibrer la
zone la moins dense des yvelines sans
argent public sans argent public
honnêtement un certain nombre d'acteurs
y compris institutionnels doutait
vraiment que de l'opposition avoir des
résultats même voire même des candidats
en réalité nous avons eu trois candidats
voilà donc oui il ya eu deux 2 candidats
malheureux
ceci étant dit les trois offres étaient
vraiment de bonne qualité et celle qui a
gagné avait évidemment un cran de plus
que les autres mais les trois offres
auraient pu chacune prises
individuellement être retenu les
permettre de faire de faire le projet
marin titre en tant que sénatrice allocs
du département est évidemment vous
regarder de près si bas il n'ya pas trop
justement de fractures à la tête des
pertes entre d'inégalités où il
important oui c'est tout est fin prêt
vert kick ass éléments côtoyer oui oui
c'est tout à fait important soit pour
les pour les territoires pour les
services que les territoires veulent
offrir à leurs concitoyens alors aux
usagers c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs lorsque la proposition de loi
a été déposée par mon collègue
et moi désigné en tant que rapporteur
l'un de mes premiers réflexes ça a été
aussi de me nourrir de ce qui se passait
dans mon département puisque je connais
un certain nombre de choses mais donc
nous avons été
voilà j'ai travaillé de près avec mon
département avec l' agence du numérique
de manière à nous assurer que ce texte
de loi pouvez aussi prendre en charge un
certain nombre de sujets qui nous était
un tout petit peu plus spécifique
c'est le jeu du travail parlementaire
c'est que lorsqu'un texte est déposée
que les différents parlementaires
puissent aussi l'amendé et lui permettre
de vivre et de s'adapter au plus près du
territoire que chacun des parlementaires
représentent 7 ainsi que mon collègue
alain schmitz a déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements que j'ai pu introduire et
que j'ai pu présenter donc à mes
collègues toute la place et que ces
amendements ont pu être votée parce que
c'est important pour pour des
territoires des villages etc pour
l'attractivité
c'est important c'est à dire que sans
sans le haut débit par exemple n'y a pas
de télétravail possible il ya donc on
peut attirer des gens grâce à ça enfin
c'est donc c'est fondamental la laurent
rochette 2020 vous tiendrez des délais
absolument les délais seront tenus tous
les tous les signes sont au vert sur le
sujet
les
les premières prises seront livrés dans
le premier trimestre 2010 9 donc tout à
fait en phase avec le calendrier qui
avait été annoncé et quand on dit oui à
prissé 20000 prise ils sont livrés voilà
donc il n'y a absolument aucune
difficulté a surgi sur le sur le
calendrier a toutes les chances d'être
retenu oui je voulais rebondir peut-être
sur les usages ce que vous venez de
d'indiquer à yves les numériques nous
développons aussi des usages plus
spécifiquement public je pense au
numérique pour l'éducation par exemple
dans les collèges dans les écoles et
c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas avoir de
rupture imaginer les enfants qui assure
bénéficier du très haut débit très forte
au bénéficie du des manuels numériques
quand il rentre à la maison
il faut de manière indispensable qui
retrouve le même environnement pour
pouvoir travailler de manière normale
merci infiniment le rush est divine
numérique et merci merci fille
infiniment martens idrac donc ses
partisans et voilà donc le haut débit
est bien partie sur le territoire
c'est ce qu'on peut conclure merci afin
d'aider à tous les deux merci
[Musique]